yo i wanted to ask you did you and gilly
the kid ever chop it up after he was you
know uh you guys got into your no we
didn't you never did no you're very
adamant about keeping positivity around
you at all times i feel like i've
noticed that about you like
like if somebody's on some weirdo like
i'm not saying he is shout out to gilly
i'm a fan of the podcast but i mean in
terms of like i've seen like you be on
shows with other artists um
and they're just like not allowed in the
dressing room because the energy they're
off yeah yeah you know what i mean
because i like to help people
you know i'm a very positive person
so if
if i could help you i will and uh
did you learn that from snoop you feel
like
yeah well snoop's the big homie you know
and there's a lot of there was a lot of
situations like back in the day
that didn't even get past certain things
because snoop a call and be like yo
that's my little homie like
chill you know what i'm saying like
don't do that
and that was always i appreciated that
because he just knows my heart he knows
the people who are around me too
he's like look
just chill just relax